تتحرك الصفائح التكتونيه تحت الارض وترتطم
ببعضها مسببه الزلازل وهذه الحركه مستمره
منذ ملايين السنين هذه هي الصفائح
التكتونيه التي تقع فوقها تركيا الصفيحه
التكتونيه الاوراسيه العربيه والاناضول
والافريقيه وتتحرك هذه الصفائح بعكس اتجاه
عقارب الساعه تظهر بيانات الاقمار
الصناعيه حركه الصفائح التكتونيه
وانزياحها بنحو ثلاثه امتار كانت قوه
الارتطام هنا تعادل طاقه تطلقها نحو 500
قنبله نوويه من قنابل هورشيما تحت الارض
نتحدث عن الطاقه التي اطلقها الزلزال
الاول فقط وكانت هذه هي النتيجه
اما منطقه كهرمان مراش تكونت فيها فجوه
نتيجه حركه الصفائح التكتونيه وكانت هذه
هي النتيجه
[موسيقى]
انقسمت هذه الاثار على عشر ولايات تركيه
اضافه الى شمال غرب سوريا اخيرا ادى هذا
الزلزال الى تضرر نحو 19 مليون شخص بينهم
13 مليون ونصف المليون في تركيا وخمسه
ملايين ونصف المليون في سوريا